j'ai essayé le nouveau casque de réalité
mixte de HTC le vive Xa Elite c'est un
truc de fou pourquoi parce qu'en fait
vous pouvez l'utiliser comme un casque
de réalité virtuelle et vous avez un peu
une autre fonctionnalité qui vous permet
de déclencher une petite caméra que vous
avez sur le devant c'est une caméra RGB
caméra en couleur qui vous permet
d'avoir de la réalité mixte et j'ai
l'impression de voir comme avec mes
propres yeux donc je vois ma pièce par
exemple et je peux venir me mettre une
statue que je viens dessiner avoir
différentes applications ce casque coûte
1399 euros il va pas forcément être fait
pour le grand public mais je ne vois
plus en usage professionnel alors si
vous voulez jouer également avec vous
pouvez le faire grâce au WiFi 6e ou
alors carrément plus branchant filaire
si on le souhaite il va se régler très
facilement grâce à une petite molette
que vous avez derrière en plus de ça
vous avez quatre caméras de suivi à
champ large de vision tout ça pour une
résolution combinée de 3840 par 1920
pixels un champ de vision de 110 degrés
d'autres rafraîchissement 90 Hertz et en
plus de ça vous avez de l'audio immersif
parce que sur les montures vous avez des
haut-parleurs qui vous permettent
d'entendre ce qui se passe dans le monde
virtuel mais vous avez surtout les
oreilles libres pour entendre ce qui se
passe autour de vous est-ce que ça
pourrait vous intéresser d'ailleurs
dites-le-moi dans les commentaires